hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen motto
review da wir uns sehr zurzeit im
dezember in der winterlichen jahreszeit
befinden vielleicht schneit es bei euch
auch draußen gerade ich weiß nicht bei
uns ist nur matsch und regen und kacke
draußen ja es regnet bonns kacke egal
zurück zum motto dieser mod fügt eskimos
dörfer ein neues bio eier place ist ihr
seht im hintergrund stand pinguine und
ich bei jeder führen auch den passenden
skin angezogen zwar so ein eskimo skin
habe ich mich mal so einfach angezogen
und ja ich wollte dem motto ich einfach
mal vorstellen weil ich den doch sehr
cool finde ich wollte den ganzen ort
schon vor zwei drei wochen vorstellen
hat mir dann allerdings gedacht da sind
noch so viele bugs trend ist immer
lieber allerdings wurden die dax immer
noch nicht behoben und deswegen zeige
ich euch das jetzt einfach mal so also
ich geh mal kurz in games zeigt euch
hier mal so das neue bio das hinzugefügt
wird ich musste ein bisschen herum
fliegen die sich gefunden
ich kann immer kurz mit f3 hier die
ganzen sachen zeigen man sieht also
könnt ihr euch einfach kopieren wenn ihr
das da drin hat und so sieht das bio
maus es kann überall auftreten hier sind
so kleine schweben der inseln teilweise
da sind auch als alle dahinter auch noch
eine wenn man das ist einfach eine
riesige schneeband unterhalt noch
eisenstadt unter snow darunter stone und
überall stehen diese kleinen häuser und
diese kleinen männchen dort habe ich
übrigens auch noch ein video gefunden
ganz witzig und ich habe mir das hier
einfach mal so ein bisschen aufgebaut
das ich euch das hier so ein bisschen
zeigen kann also dass hier sind diese
kleinen häuschen
die besteht aus diesem dunklen holz aus
diesen als labs hier oben das fire place
auf ich da oben draufgesetzt und hier
sind so kleine stückchen da kann man
dann da reingehen
das einzige was hier drin sind ein paar
fackeln hier liegt ein bett zum beispiel
und eine kiste wo nichts neues und ein
des panel ein verlies wo nix drin ist
also die häuser bringt eigentlich
relativ wenig jetzt findet übrigens die
ganze sache die auch im creative modder
sie hier ist inzwischen spawn pinguin
firewalls von eskimo hier sind die
starts dazu komme ich später hierzu
kommt auch noch später hierzu kommen
auch noch später und hierzu kommt ja
auch noch später
und ich würde sagen also diese dieses be
on board hinzugefügt das ist das arctic
bio und ja wie schon gesagt wenn ihr dem
link sie sind ein paar bugs dann zum
beispiel also in den mut zum beispiel
liegen hier teilweise einfach so
redstone fackeln rom neben häusern
ich weiß habe ich euch das kurzem zeigen
kann weil ich habe die welt wirklich
schon sehr lange
dort heißt bei mir werden da
wahrscheinlich keine warum liegen weil
die dann einfach des sports sind aber
ich würde sagen sagen wir von direkt an
und zwar sind eben diesen häusern leben
die eskimos und diese eskimos die sehen
so sehen sie aus wie normale villiger
nur die haben einen anderen skin die
sehen aus wie ich wir sehen gleich aus
naja gut okay und diese leute die haben
16 hertz das heißt man muss die schon
ein wenig aufschlagen bis sie dann
letztendlich mal ein bisschen kaputt
gehen das dauert hier noch ein bisschen
mit den hoffentlich kaputt hier also
egal ihr habt schon auf jeden fall schon
gesehen
dann tritt man mal wieder dieser and
soul auf da hinten findet ihr ein
da vorne wo bin ich hier bin ich da da
hinten war auch noch irgendwo einer ich
sehe den grad gar nicht da ist egal
jedenfalls treten die überall immer mal
so auf und die kann man ganz normal
abbauen nur ist doch wieder das problem
es gibt wieder ein bug und zwei oder
einmal gegen und der blog ist kaputt
obwohl ich im gaylord 0 bin und ich
bekomme daraus diese entziehen obwohl
ich daraus eigentlich diese bei starts
bekommen sollte also eigentlich war mal
wieder in game note 1 das ist ein
kleiner bach dieser tritt überlaufen
schon gesagt hat und ihr als älteste
einfallen lässt zeit ziemlich blöd
jedenfalls kann man sich aus diesen 1
chart sie da geglaubt werden tools
machen sage ich mal und zwar geht es
damit bisher nur eine spitzhacke und ein
schwert das heißt wenn ich das jetzt
irgendwie so mache hier funktioniert das
nicht also ich kann damit keine schaufel
machen und auch keine angst aber ich
kann damit eine packs wachen und ein
schwert und die sind genauso stark wie
eisen sachen nur die heißen halt eis und
haben eine andere textur und sie halten
tausend benutzern das heißt ich kann
damit tausende einprügeln oder 1000
blöcke mit kaputt machen also schon ganz
geil sieht ein bisschen aus wie diamant
ich finde es allerdings die textur ist
damit die schönste die hier in minecraft
gesehen habe und finde ich eigentlich
ganz schön so also das sind die tools
was ich damit machen kann dann kann ich
das sehr enkel schon wegschmeißen geld
mit den pinguinen
so können ein bisschen mitspielen
eigentlich hast es gab mir den kopf
geworfen bekommen du es jetzt egal
so die nächste sachen ist das fyrguth
und zwar kräftig man sich das so man
braucht fünf sticks macht die so in linz
am kreuz
damit kommt man das verbot das habe ich
ja schon überall hin gesetz trete schon
das kann dir dann einfach irgendwo
hinsetzen wenn jetzt mal kaputt macht es
halt wieder kaputt so zac geburt bekommt
ja auch nicht wieder und das coole an
dem ding ist das macht einfach licht das
heißt ihr braucht quasi einfach nur fünf
sticks und keine kohle oder so um
irgendwie dann nicht selten gesehen das
macht schon ganz gutes licht wenn ich
jetzt irgendwo hinfliegen beleuchtung
ist er schon zack ist schon ein hammer
heftige beleuchtung oder lass mich mal
hier
deswegen habe ich dir auch über
hingestellt damit ihr das ein bisschen
sieht wenn ich jetzt hier auf nacht
stelle und na ja also das natürlich
nicht die einzige beleuchtung die man
machen kann sondern wenn ihr das feuer
gut habt könnt ihr aus droben drei
gremmel unten drei kreml und dann einen
bars und firebird könnt ihr einen feier
place machen
den könnt ihr auch irgendwo hinsetzen
der macht allerdings kein licht ich
verstehe nicht warum es gibt hier noch
wenn ich mal wenn die items gm endlich
zeigt euch das mal ganz kurz gibt es
hier unten noch einen zweiten feier
place hat sich das thema kurz hinter der
macht licht ich weiß nicht warum warum
der licht macht und der nicht dass es
irgendwie so ein glück also dass irgend
was drin ist ein bisschen komisch aber
okay gibt es auf jeden fall auch also
die kann man sich ja auch aus diesen
dingen die menschen teil die ihre kraft
ich pack das man als christ also wieder
rein egal hier muss ein schönes leben
zurück so also das war der feier place
das kann man übrigens auch noch als
dekoration benutzen und sich eigentlich
ganz schön aus unserem blog vermeldet
wenn man den herrn irgendwie sich so dar
einstellt oder so dann würde ich sagen
mach ich mal ganz kurz wieder tag kannst
auch bei nacht verlassen hatte ich ein
tag ein bisschen schöner und wir kommen
zu den pinguinen die pinguine könnt ihr
euch spannen lassen indem er hier
spontan macht transporten hier welche
die können auch einfach so bauen
allerdings habe ich keine gefunden und
ich hatte richtige durch welchen zu
suchen nur leider ist das problem wenn
ihr das und dann zur nummer zwei auf
einmal der eine bewegt sich und der
andere web einfach so stehen
das heißt mit dem könnte auch nichts
machen wenn ihr den schlag das bei dem
genau gleich wenn ihr den schlag der
luft ein weg beziehungsweise stirbt so
wie ihr schon seht die droppen hier nur
erfahrung eigentlich droppen sie vor
feuer ist das wasser fr das heißt auf
deutsch übersetzt hält also pelz und aus
diesem pelz das sind dinge die sehen so
ein bisschen aus wie dieser ice charts
hier die sind dann so sage ich mal wenn
ihr die dann so anordnet wie eine
rüstung dann bekommt ihr auch eine farce
also eine eine vereine eine pelz zu
rüstung sage ich mal
die sieht dann genau so aus wie das was
ich hier gerade an habe nur halt noch
als rüstung und die sache ist einfach
die dass es auch ein bug und zwar
droppen die hier nichts bei mir nicht
also die die gruppe hier nur erfahrung
das ist eigentlich ganz komisch und nein
also wie schon gesagt der mord hat
einige bugs aber ich finde gerade dieses
video wird der entwickler vielleicht
einmal angespornt
ich sag mal an dem mord noch mal ein
bisschen zu werkeln
so also die pinguine treten überall auf
und dann nochmal drei andere sachen die
eigentlich bei die bald hinzugefügt
werden bzw hinzugefügt wurden aber
wieder raus genommen wurden und zwar
sind das eisbären snows labs und schnee
füchse eisbären haben neun herzen die
droppen rohes fleisch wartet die zeigen
dass ober fleisch das habe ich in
münchen eingelegt da das ist paula
vermied wenn das so ist dann macht es
einen food point also wenn ich jetzt
hier im game mode 0 da macht das einen
von von diesen sachen hier weg und wenn
das gebraten ist dann macht das drei bis
vier wieder gut das heißt wenn ich jetzt
hier sein gebratenes ging es kann ich
jetzt gerade nicht weil ich jetzt nicht
nicht ausgebaut bin aber egal ihr wisst
glaube ich was ich meine
dann gibt es schnee füchse die sind auch
noch nicht dabei die wurde noch nie
hinzugefügt aber die werden bald in
zukunft also wurden schon angekündigt
dazu haben die aufnahmen herzen die
truppen auch vor sowie pinguine wird die
sind doppelt so schnell wie alle anderen
mops und die fliehen wenn man sie steht
dazu verglichen ungefähr mit einem
ozelot kann man das machen
verglichen mit einem ozelot kann man das
machen und ja aus diesem fall wie schon
gesagt haben sich dann halt die
verkrustung machen und die skepsis ist
einfach eine halbe als nobler das heißt
wenn jetzt der schnee hat hier sind sie
dann halt einfach halb so groß sage ich
mal
und die sache ist die moment ich nehme
hier so ein bisschen schnee mit ich habe
die ganze zeit überlegt wie man sich
denn sowas crafted crafted man sich das
so erwartet man sich das so irgendwie
nie es geht nämlich alles nicht und zwar
wurde das auch noch nicht hinzugefügt
und die wurden bei mir auch wenn ich
jetzt hier hier suchen oder in two
months wenn ich oben 10 1 gebe ich finde
nur den normalen schnee die schneebälle
und den normalen blog hält aber dann
kann die sich halt noch nicht greifen
und deswegen kann ich euch nicht zeigen
aber dass
ein halber snow block und na ja also ich
denke ihr wisst schon was damit meinung
so dass porsche jetzt auch ein bisschen
versichern ich würde sagen das war
erstmal der arctic mord ich hoffe euch
hat es gefallen wenn es euch gefallen
hat schaffen wir vielleicht 800 likes
für diesen geilen mord weil dadurch sehe
ich einfach dass religiös gefallen dass
ich eventuell mehr machen soll und dass
ich auf dieser mod gefällt oder diesel
muss man ja auch einige legen diese
modifikation dieser mod hat sich bei mir
einfach eingebürgert und na ja ich will
mich auf jeden fall meine positive
bewertung freuen download-links facebook
etc
in der beschreibung der seite immer auf
dem neuesten stand wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal freunde zschau